what a crazy game this was fabiano
welcome to the studio tell us about your
preparation it seemed very deep when did
you stop remembering and start
calculating
well i was a bit disappointed because i
i hope this h3 would come as at least a
small surprise
all the way back here
yeah it's a very rare move but it has
been played but i was hoping that
he wouldn't um be as familiar with it or
he wouldn't recall exactly how to play
against it
uh but he
he knew everything
like up until nine to five i'm pretty
sure
up to knight f5 even inclusive 95 out of
here well i was i was really hesitant
because after bishop b6 i can do some
out of control stuff involving like
queen e2 we need two instead of f4 g6
yes we have three
b5
bishop e4
rook b8 and i just thought okay i don't
know what's going on
bishop c6 rook of fate
and it's i was worried that he that his
attack will crash through and i'll get
mated
so okay i played a rather controlled way
which was trying to equalize this is
still in your file like i knew that this
was a sort of bailout a bailout okay and
at this point i thought okay i should
probably bail out and um i guess i'm
like a tiny bit worse after queen d5 if
he plays
queen e6
all right 26 i'm sorry queen
queen takes and ambition h3
i mean i guess white equalizes here but
i'd rather be black
yeah i was surprised that he went for
bishop f2 very forcing yeah it might be
a draw but uh it looks like white has
the easier time of it do you remember
this move or was it not considered
um
no i i didn't really analyze this
position i mean i just kind of knew that
white is more or less equalizing here
and uh
and i really didn't expect bishop f2
yeah it just looks dangerous
and okay i see
double question mark somewhere
don't worry about that just yet so
this followed this is absolutely forced
and now instead of going for a draw you
decided to keep the game alive with rook
takes you one i didn't see exactly how
black plays it after rookie one i
thought maybe rook 88 yeah rookie dave
was definitely the best move according
to the engine but yeah i thought that
white isn't definitely not worse like
it's hard to imagine white being worse
here and i i even thought i could play
slowly like h4 or something it didn't
seem
it didn't seem like i i have any like
only moves here right um so he plays
rook f8
yeah went through your mind queen d7 i
thought queen b6 i i really didn't see
anything there queen b6 knight f7 king
g8 and then rookie seven
um
[Music]
why is this winning 95 next move i guess
knight h6 checked well now they're 16
years kj like
so wait if queen f2 then knight e5
oh would that
go so far it's so deep here but do you
have a perpetual queen of one queen d3
traits the queens
king b1 i think we can go knight d5 yeah
i i think we can go ninety five then
okay let's say he takes two pawns
and d5 knight f7 right uh and then queen
define knight f7 okay yeah queen d5 here
just to show knight f7 picks up this
queen
can't defend this way
so you got you saw the move queen b6 and
didn't fully see i i saw this and i
thought like black picks up g5 and uh
and i didn't fully believe in it because
my king looks very open right so
yeah i just um
and if kwijji went first then
then king c2
g1 here can i assume c2 we have two yeah
we go to be one two three one take and
now probably
might be five foot anyway five again you
know ninety five four ninety five seems
winning but i might even have knight age
six knight six king gatesh8 because he
defends h7 by spinning for check
and he has rook f1 counter play
um
i guess i i mean no but 95 queen five it
can't be 95 here yeah so so
maybe it's just
okay knight h6
king h8 take queen e4 king a2 we're
maybe losing here to rook f1 and then
rook f1 knight f7 and knight ah we're
we're winning we're waiting
but i think it might hinge on something
like this something very concrete down
the line yeah it's like
basically 20 move i mean knocking out 20
moves but it's it's a very long line and
uh and probably all hinges on like a
detail at the very end right a little
bit later in the game we did have this
position you played before you found
this great move knight c6 must have
caught him by surprise
taking the knight seemingly away from
the attack but cutting off the queen and
after rook c8 97 rook ce8 he decided to
start with the move queen h4 uh why did
you decline the move f6 yeah i thought
queen h4 was winning
um but wait f6 gf and g6 right yes
yeah yeah this is this is probably uh
there's just no moves he's completely
dominated yeah i just thought queen h4
queen d6 for q4 was winning and i
i um
well i i thought there was even like a
few things i might be winning but then i
couldn't find anything it is not winning
at that point yeah which is unfortunate
like um
[Music]
yeah i just didn't see what to do like i
was thinking instead of rookie four
knight g6
king g8 rook d1 is very interesting
sorry instead of instead of rookie four
rookie four knight g6 king g8 and rook
d1 rook d1 yes and then he has queen d1
king d1 rook f5
oof i'm trapping the knight knight f4
rook e4
g6
hg queen d8 king gage seven
and my knight gets lost like it it was
kind of
remarkable to me but yeah i guess my
king is is really chronically weak yes
yeah
i just need to take a draw with queen h4
absolutely
father you didn't find the correct move
in this one to finish off the game do
you think that it was just too difficult
or do you think that form is affecting a
little bit no well the first one was
difficult but the second one with f6 was
not too difficult i just rushed to queen
h4
um
yeah i don't know i also was affected
but by his time he was very long time
and right
for some reason i thought i should play
quickly but
um but that wasn't a good idea
yeah f6 is really not difficult because
um
there's like two very logical moves ones
queen h4 one's f6 and
if you start to calculate f6 it it does
look
it does look really devastating
absolutely probably two rounds so far in
the sing field how do you feel
uh yeah today wasn't ideal um
it's a bit disappointing that i missed
uh more than one
win but
you know uh hopefully it gets better
well we hope so as well fabiano carona
with one point out of two guys any
questions from the panel a quick
question for you fabi uh hans niemann he
comes into this tournament as the lowest
rated player
in the event big target on hansa's back
and he's performed
admirably in the first two rounds your
thoughts
well i'm not terribly surprised i mean
he's capable of beating
uh the best players in the world and
and that show today
um
yeah he seems to be in good form so i
but i don't think this is like so so
shocking that he that he beats chakriar
it can happen
all right fair enough thank you and good
luck
for the remaining rounds